it's great to be joined today by Travis
Lepik who is an award winner I did you
sail epic or loop ik now I'm doubting
Luther you did I loop ik take it from
the top here we go it's great to be
joined today by Travis loop ik who's an
award-winning journalist and author of
the book fighting for space how a group
of drug users transformed one city
struggle with addiction referencing your
work in Vancouver which is very very
interesting let's start Travis if we can
with you're sort of just a fundamental
question is there something uniquely
different about the opioid epidemic that
we're currently experiencing than other
drug epidemics that we've seen in the
past the drug crisis that all North
America faces today is is different from
similar crises of the past because of
fentanyl this may be began in a lot of
areas for prescription drugs but it is
now very much a heroin and fentanyl
crisis and for those who didn't know
fentanyl is a synthetic opiate that's
significantly more stronger than heroin
and usually when users are taking drugs
there they don't know the fentanyl
that's this dangerous substances in
there so there's there's that extra
degree of uncertainty in the crisis
we're facing today that makes us a
really tricky problem with regard to how
law enforcement and first responders are
sort of trained and empowered to deal
with a parent or potential or real
overdoses talk a little bit about how
you feel that things like police
carrying narcan and other sort of rescue
medications relates to the broader
treatment of this epidemic is that
generally something that we like the
results of or that we should be
concerned about it's getting better
law enforcement's role in responding to
this crisis it wasn't until recently
that a lot of police officers were even
carrying the so-called overdose antidote
naloxone so it's good to see them
involved interestingly though in
Vancouver police actually don't respond
to an overdose call when someone calls
my
one for an overdose that call is does
not go to a police department it only
goes to fire and ambulance which the
idea is hopefully removes a degree of
hesitation that some of you drug users
might have to call 9-1-1
yeah and and that gets to the the sort
of discussion around decriminalization
versus legalization and you know in the
United States when it comes to marijuana
there's sort of a patchwork of laws
depending on the state that you're in of
course marijuana is still illegal at the
federal level and there's this big
debate about decriminalization as a good
first step towards legalization versus
the idea that these are sort of two
really separate paths with very very
different implications can you talk a
little bit about that I mean it
practically speaking why is the
difference between decriminalization and
legalization so important yeah I mean
that's I'm so happy I asked that
question because I think it is one of
the most important questions that we
have in this debate on drug policy in
the context of the crisis right now
decriminalization deals with the demand
side so all decriminalization does is
remove criminal laws that make it
illegal people the whole drugs for
personal possession legalization goes
the next step it's much more complicated
it involves fully legalizing and
regulating substances sort of some
possibly similar to how we regulate
tobacco and alcohol
so the idea advocates for
decriminalization say would remove
stigma would bring drug use to be open
it would help it would encourage people
to seek help seek treatment but it would
not solve the fentanyl crisis that we
talked about earlier decriminalization
would leave supply in the hands of
dealers an organized crime whereas
legalization the next step would remove
drug supply from organized crime and
bring it under the control of government
right so even in cases where we've seen
legalization like for example in
Colorado in the United States with
marijuana it doesn't eliminate the black
market but it significantly reduces it
does decriminalization do anything at
all to deal with the black market aspect
of the supply it really doesn't and
while I'm an advocate for
decriminalization this is why I think we
have to be cautious about it it's a
first
step in my opinion but it would not
solve the fentanyl crisis supply would
remain in the hands of organized crime
and organized crime would continue to
poison really poison these drugs with
fentanyl what about the public sort of
stigma I guess or let me rephrase it a
different way do you have any strong
feeling as to whether legalization more
drastically changes the public
perspective on a particular substance
compared to just decriminalization yeah
again I think the criminalization is an
important first step because I do
believe it would learn it would go a
long way in changing public opinions
towards drug use if drug use is no
longer a criminal matter we can we can
truly let it become a healthcare matter
and encourage people to speak treatment
speak about and more openly because it
won't be criminal anymore um
legalization would continue that process
they would sort of normalize normalized
drug use and I mean that in a positive
way I it would allow people to use drugs
out in the open I'm not using drugs
alone where if they overdose there's no
one to catch them if they they overdose
and it would it would allow us to
control how how the public perceives
drugs for example a lot of jurisdictions
have a large warning labels on packages
of cigarettes we can do the same sort of
thing with dangerous drugs as opposed to
leaving market in the in the hands of
organized crime areas now can you tell
us more about what's been done in
Vancouver you already talked about how
when you call emergency services for
possible or actual overdose in Vancouver
police don't respond you basically have
ambulance and and firefighters and that
it's really dealt with as a health
incident not as a criminal incident what
else has been done in Vancouver yeah so
first to give people an idea of the
scale of the problem here Vancouver's
over overdose crisis is about on par
with Philadelphia's is a good comparison
but 50 overdose deaths per hundred
thousand people is the rate and then
that is an astronomical rate of
overdoses it's something really scary in
response and the government has taken
some really radical measures mostly
since the winter of 2016 so when you
call 9-1-1 police don't show up call
only goes to medical and fire we have
essentially flooded the streets with the
overdose antidote naloxone and it's free
you get it over the counter in
pharmacies you walk down the street in
Vancouver you see it clip the people's
belts it's really everywhere we've also
opened a ton of new sort of low barriers
supervised injection sites places where
people can bring bring illegal drugs
mostly heroin cocaine and
methamphetamine and used them under the
watchful care of staff we can respond in
the event of an overdose Vancouver of
course established North America's first
supervised injection site in 2003 we
only had that one site for the entire
next decade since the winter of 2016 our
city alone is open more than half a
dozen additional sites and they're
reversing overdoses every single day so
there are people who will hear you talk
about you know supervised places to use
for recreational drug use and they'll
say that in the net will increase the
number of people engaging in risky
behavior with drugs what evidence do we
have to push back against that talking
point yeah and and I do understand that
talking point there is logic behind it
but the data does not actually tell us
that's what occurs in sight at North
America's first supervised injection
site in Vancouver since 2003 is very
possibly and the most studied health
intervention in our continents history
there was data collected in the
neighborhood around in sight before
insite opened and data collected in the
neighborhood around in sight after
inside opened and it shows that there
was no increase in drug use what did
occur is it brought people who were
using drugs inside off the street into a
safe place brought them out of the
alleys into a healthcare environment
where there was some where through the
way that where there was someone to
respond to an overdose since these
additional half dozen plus injection
sites have opened in Vancouver since the
winter of 2016
they've received over 200,000 visits
there's been hundreds of overdoses and
at any of them can you talk a little bit
about how we can get accurate data about
drug use and the reason I ask that is
that very often when you are making an
attempt to compare a drug use rate prior
to an after decriminalization or prior
to and after legalization you have to
contend with the reality that people
might be differently willing to admit to
drug use based on the change in the
status of a particular drug so how does
science and the statistical world
account for that when we talk about free
and post drug use levels sure I mean
there is a challenge there but
especially in Vancouver but also across
the United States researchers have been
working on this question for a long time
academic researchers scientists were
actually really involved in establishing
insite there was a couple of fantastic
doctors named Thomas Kerr and Evan wood
who worked in the community for long
enough to sort of build up or the tour
with drug users there's all sorts of
sort of them they build safeguards into
this research now a sort of tries to
compensate for different changes in
people's opinions and this is pretty
well established science now in
Vancouver at least more than 30 years
old and in a lot of areas of Ni the
United States and much more established
than people might think can you talk a
little bit about where in the world we
can look to for results about models
that are sort of in the style of what's
being done in Vancouver I mean I know
colloquially people often like to talk
about Portugal and sometimes will
incorrectly hear policy ascribed to
Portugal that's not exactly accurate so
sort of like what other models around
the world are there that are relevant
here well Portugal is a good one for us
to look to that's where they implemented
decriminalization over a decade ago but
like you said I agree with you it's not
a perfect comparison for North America
right now but that's Portugal has never
had to deal with fentanyl and like we
were saying a minute ago
decriminalization would not remove that
nor from organized crime so but there
are other there's other aspects or the
Portugal story that I think we should
look at when they decriminalized drugs
when they in some people's minds made
reviews more acceptable drug use did not
increase drug use decreased overdose
deaths decreased the spread of HIV
decreased and so the Portugal story is
not perfect but I bet I think we can't
look to it because there's a lot of
successes there we've been speaking with
Travis Lubich he's an award-winning
journalist also author of the book
fighting for space how a group of drug
users transformed one city's struggle
with addiction Travis really great work
and I really appreciate you talking to
me today thank you so much for having me
on